and the spirit awards for best for is
feature ghost you
[Music]
selden met oh my name is luc robotics
the savior that microphone that this is the dl
to my fear so tired by this board and
am thinking biology water filmmakers and
discovery the other categories  or zo there
3 million
amai my picture in amalfi producer such
pixar nuance roundtable with beach
crisis and check if you're never was a
wish i could look i am aisha death by
the way als zo en kourtney and assess
your words to it  in celebrates all
views producers and everybody your
career at sars so wonderful your
supporter this film person many years
and very very deep my special iburg
social who all love and brei is film
together
new creative selling point for may
you were great if you could amplifon de
dear god man women supplications and
very very high bar en who perform
delicate belge des finances need much
more in the world we push
nobody in hollywood words and your did
and cava single  s because of you can
action te de script en zo rider
that is the best h13 french aan mijn en
lavvy die
en your heart is you already beat about it the
movie in summer i was on a quest en meaning
to you are for you so important  this
movie and a wat cider in tyler cast and
crew there is also a talk to each and
every one review by in al die actors and
guys my dreams controller is paul le
violon rip off with sean work a good guys
just so incredibly de smeagol too  ever
to my kins
name and love you guys syria boffin this
movie interfaces is in the art
apartment which i am so why i will
always treasure here we see give my
brother ray for him what he same and
received within this together i thought
i treasure formal  never forget that
really just idle movie in the man in the
house
f noliko in bree back
aan en site fast last time i was week and
hang all of you guys and a thank you so
much
between the session enable